the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show the
second to last bonus show before the
election i am increasingly nervous i I'd
keep when people ask me all sorts of
people will say to me Pat as if I know
anything right what what do you think's
going to happen in this election about
my opinion is one of tens of millions uh
and I say you know I think Hillary has
the numbers but I don't know if I'm
falling victim to the it's really close
narrative that is mostly being
perpetrated by the Trump campaign I
really don't know but I am nervous if
you ask me two or three weeks ago I
would have said easy landslide and it
would be entertaining to watch the
demise of Trump yeah but since the
second email story broke I mean it's
gotten a lot closer and even though
there's been good some good news for
Hillary Clinton in the past couple days
it to literally lay signs it's it's
gonna be questionable I am I mean if if
you ask me what's the most likely
scenario I think it's Hillary Clinton
has this wrapped up by 10 p.m. eastern
I've I think the most likely scenario is
that by 10pm Eastern we know that
Hillary Clinton will be the next
president of the United States is it
possible that we find out at eleven that
Donald Trump has one yeah I think it is
and that is absolutely horrifying to me
well even in 2008 it was a relative
landslide but we didn't know until
eleven o'clock eastern that Obama had
one right as that's when California
Oregon Washington the results come in so
really can add those numbers in ahead of
time and we'll probably see around ten
o'clock we'll see how close it is in
2012 it was at ten o'clock that we knew
right because wasn't it Ohio's ohio ohio
was called at ten o'clock even though i
think ohio closes at nine i think it was
called for Obama at ten I might be
mixing up two thousand eight and twenty
twelve now I don't know I mean depending
on how close it is and what the exit
poll numbers look like yet to be called
right away and it could be called hours
after a days after yeah if there's one
or two states that are going to decide
the election like North Carolina Florida
right we night we may not even know that
day yet let's hope that doesn't happen
I'm hoping that I can be a home
by 11 and uh you know in bed by eleven
twenty although I don't know that that's
going to happen and that gets me to we
are doing live election coverage I got a
bunch of emails from people saying are
you going to be doing something I will
be here and then Dixon will be here and
the whole team is actually going to be
here we'll be doing live election
coverage starting at seven ish maybe
like 650 will do 10 minutes and then
we'll have the first major results at
seven pm eastern couple states close at
6pm but really the big first closings
are at seven o'clock we've been setting
up a system where I will have my laptop
and I'll be able to fill in the map as
we go and we'll all be able to watch it
and see it i think it's going to be
great we are going to be taking calls
throughout this process and i think it's
going to be great i hope people join us
technically it's it's going to be I
don't think it's gonna be a challenge
technically but Ben and I are going to
be doing some testing of the system
today this will be YouTube live that's
the key thing now the live election
coverage will be on YouTube live will be
dipping in and out of uh national news
coverage will be hopefully checking in
with sam cedar at the majority report
and I think hopefully it will go well
you never know but I'm hoping that we
have a positive situation well I think
regardless of what side you fall on here
yet you're more liberal or conservative
depending on who you're supporting sure
to enjoy this because you're gonna even
either see our joy or our despair yeah
at either tech my guess is that either
10pm or 11 p.m. eastern there will
either be be a very relieved I don't
know about joy I will either be relieved
that we will have a center left to
Center right Democrat that one or I will
be absolutely horrified that arguably
the most unqualified presidential
candidate in the last at least hundred
years has been elected president of the
United States one of those two scenarios
will play itself out tomorrow and we
will see which of the two it is yet
anything else you want to add on this or
could be a 269 269 tie or recount or
something in this could go for months on
end you know if I had to bet it will not
be an electoral tie I saw that scenario
there's a map where if Trump wins New
Hampshire Florida and Ohio you could get
a 269 to 269 tie with Hillary Clinton I
wouldn't bet on that myself I don't
think it's happened before I mean
there's been dead locks in the elect
or college but but not a 269 to second
and I yep I don't see it happening okay
so Kim jong-un we haven't heard from
South Korean I'm sorry North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un for some time and
he is threatening a missile launch uh to
sort of I don't know welcome or
commemorate the United States elected a
new president every time that this
happens most people I know have the same
reaction initially it's it's BS don't
pay attention to it the guy just wants
attention and then number two they start
reading well you know here's what's
technologically possible based on the
military capabilities that we know North
Korea actually has and then you get
people who say oh you know what actually
maybe we should be concerned about this
and then sometimes friends of mine will
get very militaristic and they'll say
we've got to go after these this guy and
we've gotta take him out right now that
was always Louis's idea the idea of
leading some kind of coup against the
regime in North Korea liberating
everybody is some kind of heroes and
then happily ever after but things don't
exactly work that way particularly when
even though the alliance with China is a
little bit frayed for North Korea China
is not ready just to allow North Korea
to fall and China does have power I
think we see so much hilarity out of
what happens in North Korea that it's
really hard to take one of these threats
seriously individual nuclear weapons and
nuclear weapons I mean we should be
concerned especially if Trump is elected
president on election night we're
there's no telling his his temperament
when it comes to nuclear weapons yet
well we sort of know that he's okay with
more countries having them he said that
and that really got to be a concern to
us Saudi Arabia included and that that
is very very disturbing I'm a huge fan
of all the North Korea documentaries I
don't know if you've seen any of them
but vice has some we interviewed a guy a
couple years ago named Matt doors and
sick went to North Korea and did a
documentary the one where I think it's
vice goes with Dennis Rodman to North
Korea and it is complete and utter chaos
i mean it's it's insane the stuff that
goes on there I i love them i could
watch those all day i don't know if
you're a fan i have seen a couple of
them and yet the the amount of access
that Dennis Rodman has been given yeah
it's pretty hilarious how he may
be the single biggest expert as in terms
of an ambassador to a country that we
have here Dennis Rodman who was kicked
out of North Korea for defecating and
vomiting in a hotel hallway in North
Korea is the most up to date on the
current mental state of Kim jong-un on
what is going on there behind the scenes
he is the guy of all people that at
least we know about I'm there's probably
some covert clandestine operators that
are in North Korea know a lot but I
would be shocked if they had the level
of access to Kim jong-un that Dennis
Rodman had I mean it's disturbing I
hadn't heard that he had done all that
in the hotel room you think most people
and going to North Korea which are
really not even supposed to be in
according to our own government policy
right there be kind of be on pins and
needles when it comes to that sort of
thing so that's pretty surprising well
alcohol that's what channel do it for uh
for Dennis Rodman uh every time that
there is an election usually there's at
least a few people who say if this guy
or the other woman or this woman or that
guy depending on who wins I'm moving to
Canada now as we know that's interesting
and nonsense on two levels number one
it's really difficult to move to Canada
you can't just say hey I'm moving to
Canada and and move to candidates a
difficult process in terms of the
immigration process but number two if
you're a Republican and you say if the
Democrat wins I'm moving to Canada that
really makes no sense because when it
comes to government policy in basically
every way the Canadian government Canada
as a country is way to the left of the
United States so I get it when liberals
say it although it still isn't easy to
move to Canada but when conservatives
say I'll move to Canada if the Democrat
wins that will why it'd be much more
conservative to stay right it's it's at
least logically consistent when liberals
say it but when conservatives say I mean
where do you want to go that's more
conservative than the United States yes
Saudi Arabia best thing when you
actually talk to conservatives and you
say well if you'd be leaving the US
because it's too liberal your options
are not that great when it comes to
where you could go that's more
conservative i mean you're talking about
mostly islamic religious theocracies or
other extremist countries or countries
that are just in
astris condition economically uh I don't
see conservatives saying I'm sick of
this liberal BS in the US I'm moving to
Yemen but I mean it's just not going to
happen and and so that's why it's really
difficult because in many ways with the
puritanical background of the United
States this is one of the more
conservative places you can live unless
you're looking at a dip a type of
conservatism that I don't think most
American Republicans like yeah the
Democratic Party to in the United States
is kind of on par with some of the more
conservative parties elsewhere yeah look
at england germany i'm sure there's
multiple examples yet being being a
Democrat in the US is considered
basically center to center right in many
European in other countries but so not
Canada but there are countries where you
can buy citizenship and i found a list
and tiguan barb barbuda cyprus Dominica
Grenada Hungary st. lucia saint kitts
and bulgaria now the cost varies in some
places you have to make a donation in
order to qualify for citizenship in
other places like Cyprus you have to own
real estate and the real estate
apparently has to be worth around 2.1
million u.s. dollars and then in other
countries you have to own bonds so in
hungary and bulgaria you have to own
bonds government bonds in Bulgaria and
Hungary I don't know if its stock market
bonds or or or exactly what bonds you
have to own the cheapest place where you
can basically by citizenship is dominica
we're up for about a hundred and eleven
thousand dollars it's a hundred k
donation and 11,000 250 in an
application fee so a hundred and eleven
thousand two hundred and fifty dollars
will get you citizenship in Dominica now
I don't know that much about dominica
but my sense is that if you have a
domain you can passport you're pretty
much okay in most of the world right
right it's interesting looking at this
list too because a lot of these
countries are small islands in the
Caribbean so you'd have to imagine if
this is just trying to appeal to the
American cruise goer who visits and says
well if I can spend only a few hundred
thousand dollars on the essen ship I
might as well I have the money I don't
know what would be the most appeal like
if I decided
I had the money and I decided I have to
buy citizenship somewhere right like I
couldn't like I could go back to
Argentina renew my passport I'm good I'm
a citizen I was born there I could go to
Israel and go through the process of
becoming is it citizen there so I had it
but let's say I didn't have those
options and I was limited to this list
and I had to buy citizenship somewhere I
think really I would be looking at
hungary to be honest because I have
friends who have been there I've never
been there uh Budapest is apparently
beautiful you're right in the middle of
Europe in terms of access you can go to
anywhere in Europe and and very very
quickly the economy I know is not doing
particularly well but maybe I could like
continue the show from there I could
skype in every day or something like
that if I wanted to go the approach of
just like where could I hang on the
beach and the weather is nice yeah then
I'd go with one of the the island
caribbean nations or something like that
but for overall I think the most
practical one for me here would be
hungry if you look at the donation
amounts usually there around two hundred
thousand dollars three hundred thousand
dollars but far and away the most
expensive would be Cyprus where you have
to own two million dollars worth of real
estate yet that's just not a possibility
for most people the other thing and I
know that this is sort of silly but if
you look at either the comments on on
one of these articles about buying
citizenship some people say have you
seen the economy in Cyprus you'd have to
buy 50 houses to have two million
dollars in real-estate in Cyprus which
is not true it's an exaggeration but I
do understand the point economically
there is some trouble in Cyprus so where
would you go if you could pick from this
list uh of countries where you can buy
citizenship is there a preference I'm
curious what the view of the audience
would be on this do you have a choice
Pat of where you which one of these
places you would pick to buy citizenship
I'm narrowing it down to Grenada and st.
Kitts st. Kitts really that maybe I
haven't been to either one though I've
heard st. Kitts is very touristy I would
just do a google image search inside
like and pretty much go by that that's
usually how I make most decisions about
products vacations everything I just go
to images that google.com and type it in
and what looks good that's what I that's
what I by that's what I go with if you
have a small amount of time to flee the
country you may not have much time to do
much more you only have time for Google
search you might be depending on a
image search if you have any ideas for
things you want us to do tomorrow during
the live election coverage let me know
tomorrow election day you will talk to
you then the david pakman show at david
pakman.com